[Music]
for me terrence malick is a filmmaker
that almost defies discussion analysis
of his recent work seems almost
antithetical to the work itself
[Music]
nonetheless I'm deeply drawn to and
fascinated by what he's trying to do his
exploratory existentialist style seems
not to state but only to search only to
ask
he's not insisting but inciting and
while his recent work into the wonder
and Knight of cups and song to song has
enthralled me bored me inspired me and
even frustrated me at times there exists
a quality to his work that is undeniable
unique
his recent trilogy of films is so
fanatically intertwined that shots from
each are almost interchangeable
[Music]
working without a script these films
cast a side-story to become meditations
on existence
characters change locations change but
there's a consistent searching that
remains constant
he's making films that consist almost
entirely of scenes that would be cut out
of a conventional story or film or used
merely as transitional moments
[Music]
he abandons the writer centrism that
pervades the vast majority of filmmaking
and in doing so brings the choices of
the actors cinematographer location
manager and editor to the forefront I
[Music]
think for Malick the process of creation
has almost superseded the final product
the lens is searching because he is
searching in the characters search
because the actors search
these films aren't planned they are
formed by reaction the actors react to
the world and each other and the
cinematographer reacts to the actors and
the world and the editor reacts to the
rhythms constructed by the actors the
world and cinematography
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the director becomes facilitator putting
things into motion and then looking for
patterns of beauty and that motion
maybe these visual obsessions emerge
across his films not because he has
something to say about Windows
architecture in nature or sunlight well
because this is what emerges when Beauty
is looked for by actor director
cinematographer and editor with freedom
and curiosity
[Music]